what's up everyone this is Anthony
papiano most of you know me as pump
you're listening to off the chain
simply the best podcasting crypto let's
kick this thing off
[Music]
the following episode is part of the
off-the-chain automation series
sponsored by iota the goal of this
special series is to explore the
intersection of distributed ledger
technology and automation specifically
around digital currencies digital
wallets and machine-to-machine
transactions my core belief is that
every stock bond currency and commodity
will eventually be digitized and
distributed ledger technology will
empower the full potential of automation
to be realized
iota is the sponsor of the automation
series their mission is to support the
research and development of new
distributed ledger technologies
including IOT tangle the iota foundation
encourages the education and adoption of
distributed ledger technologies through
the creation of ecosystems and the
standardization of these new protocols
you can find out more about the
automation series and iota in the show
notes dominic shiner is the founder and
co-chairman of the board of directors of
iota in this conversation we discussed
the future of machine to machine
transactions how automation will become
pervasive throughout our lives where
distributed ledger technology fits in
and how iota is building solutions for
this new world I really enjoyed this
conversation and I hope you do as well
Anthony pomp Leon o is a partner at
Morgan Creek digital all opinions
expressed by pomp or his guests on this
podcast are solely their opinions and do
not reflect the opinions of Morgan Creek
digital or Morgan Creek Capital
Management you should not treat any
opinion expressed by pomp as a specific
inducement to make a particular
investment or follow a particular
strategy but only as an expression of
his opinion this podcast is for
informational purposes only
alright guys bang bang I'm sitting here
with DOM super excited to do this
episode he is one of the folks who's
probably thought even more than I have
about how machine to machine
transactions are going to evolve over
time so thank so much for coming in and
doing this thanks for having me on the
show
yeah for sure let's jump right into your
background you've been around crypto for
a really long time so what did you do
before you got into Bitcoin and crypto
so before I go to decrypt I was big into
gaming gaming yeah exactly
Call of Duty and all kinds of ps4 games
and then I realized that with games the
connection start making money and so I
kind of started getting into this whole
entrepreneurial career where I was
trying to figure out how can actually
money on internet because I really
realized that the Internet is not
Facebook it's not Twitter it's really
how you can educate yourself and build
something great and I had this whole
hustling period and what I settled
myself down to was an advertising
platform because we realized we cost per
action pay per action so on and so forth
you can really start making a lot of
money and so went on this quest to set
up my own advertising platform I tried
to get some advertisers on board and
that is actually what got me to Bitcoin
in the first place in 2011 Wow what was
the kind of trash you're building up the
advertising platform you're working on
getting advertisers on how do you go
from that to Bitcoin yeah it was a very
simple problem actually so how can I pay
my developers to make the platform
because at the time I was too young to
have a PayPal account and so my friend
introduced me to Bitcoin for the first
time I just started utilizing it and
really started becoming really and and
compassed by this vision of
permissionless innovation meaning that
you can really utilize this new
technology Bitcoin to transfer value
globally and so it solved a very simple
problem for me how can I pay my
developers and I kind of got sidetracked
with school and stuff and so then in
2012 I really got full-time into it I
started reading up on the technical
concepts behind it and really fully
understanding the hope for whole the
whole scale of this and what is what is
actually possible and then I became
fully convinced that I really want to do
something into space and so what
happened then is I started figuring out
that bitcoin is not the oniy
cryptocurrency out there but there's a
lot of potential also in all coins and
so I started out with mining all coins
the first one I did was protegees which
was created by the infamous
you're Larimer and so started out with
that and I made a bunch of money with it
and but then I realized that this is not
the end yeah there's so much more and
and the biggest potential that I saw
back in the day is how can you solve
this problem of going from Fiat from the
Fiat world into the crypto world and so
I went to this quest to set up a crypto
currency exchange
okay which even back then was a huge
huge drama to set up because you had
this whole risk with the regulatory side
with the legal side and most
predominantly with the banking side it
was impossible to get a bank account
back because the banks just said we're
not working with any crypto companies
yeah absolutely like I reached out to
banks in Ireland man I even flew there
Sweden Malta and so on and so forth and
every time it was like please never
contact us again Bitcoin is against our
internal policies and it's for money
laundering and so on and so forth and
that is actually what attracted me to
the crypto Valiant soup in 2013 Joss
Hoskinson actually invited me to meet
her because back in the day he was a CEO
of ethier he said we are setting up this
whole hoppin Duke and maybe you want to
join us in setting up a self-regulating
organization with the idea that I'm
gonna solve all of my problems
banking legal regulatory all soft in one
swoop yeah which obviously didn't happen
and mmm I I lived in Switzerland I was
living in there and a theorem house back
then what was that like what was the the
etherium house in Zook Switzerland in
2013 like so where's a bunch of guys
there was like two girls two girlfriends
of Mihai and some other guy and they
were just having fun right you could see
them create a website and be amazed so
oh my gosh it's gonna be big you could
see Charles recording the video that
he's gonna put on YouTube talking about
this grand vision and back then I didn't
really fully understand a full scale of
this I think nobody really understood to
feel scared of this way this would go
because at the time it was they were
just working on a project like everyone
else no one realized that this one
specifically is gonna go be worth tens
of billions of dollars exactly they
didn't even do their ICL so there was
just like eight to ten people in one
apartment put together sleeping on
mattresses so it was pretty crazy but it
was it really taught me a lot right
and so it was it fun it was a lot of fun
yeah and so we didn't do a lot of
partying but it was everybody was simply
wait wake up go in front of your
computer drink a bunch of coffee go out
to eat or order something and somebody
cooks you having a visit right that's
awesome
all right so you're there in the house
and then where do you do from there so
what did it from there is I still was in
school so I had to travel between
Switzerland and Italy where I was born
and then the first crash came in 2013
and of 2013 and I ended up losing all my
money which which sucked at the time so
I have really disheartened with
Switzerland because I had an apartment
there trying to think through how I can
really bring people to Switzerland build
up my huge company and everything blew
up just like that right but then I
continued and I really got more involved
on a technical side and then it was
flown in by fan [ __ ] capital to
Shanghai which was back they invited me
to the back then largest blockchain
hackathon in the world with $100,000
prize money and I ended up winning that
hackathon really yeah what did what did
you build I build a supply chain
transparency a concept with trade
finance so you can really entire process
of shipping and pain and you had a
background in computer science or how
did you learn to code I taught myself
because it got screwed over a few times
I developed a few times my developers
that I hired was like [ __ ] I'll just
learn myself uh-huh it was it hard no it
was a fun challenge and I realized that
the only way to really build something
is if you can even know how to build it
so you need to teach yourself and so I
want hackathon and I told the guys I
want to pricing either so we tell it
gave me like 30 thousand either Wow for
for winning the hackathon all right so
you win the hackathon you get thirty
thousand either what's the price is that
penance back then it was like one or two
dollars per per litre mm-hmm I said was
a pretty pretty good deal
yeah yeah absolutely do you sell more
yeah yeah of course because then when
flew back to to Europe we really started
getting serious about Iona
and so I invested everything back into
it okay so if you had thirty thousand
ether today that would be worth a lot of
money but but obviously when you get
back what was the kind of genesis so you
win the hackathon but you don't move
forward with the supply chain and the
trade finance why did you choose to kind
of leave it as a concept and not pursue
it I saw it Morris seed funding
opportunity for myself the lobby I was
broke I had no money and and back then I
also realized that the whole application
layer on top of blockchain is simply not
there yet and it's really on the
protocol level where you have the
biggest opportunity and that is why why
I got much more involved in iota
so I also pulled it all and that is
where we really realized the potential
that Iona had back in 2015 and of 2015
and that's why I focus full-time on it
and then also ended up moving to Berlin
got it
okay and so what was the original idea
for iota so it all comes from the IOT
space we are all focused on automation
how can you make our devices smarter how
can we really start connecting them with
each other my division of IOT goes
beyond just automation it goes towards
autonomy how can we make it possible for
one machine to actually independently
decide what it does with the value that
it creates meaning data or services and
at the end of the day what you get out
of that is really a machine economy one
machine transacting with another machine
and creating our own economy which has
tremendous potential for for this vision
of autonomy and of automation and we
realized that the only way to really
realize that machine economy is to
introduce a distributed ledger because
you want to remove the trust layer you
want to introduce a trust layer and you
also want to really enable it for
machines to have their own wallet to
hold their own assets and own them and
that is why yes let's talk for a second
about the machine to machine transaction
so I think this is something that people
may hear that terminology a lot did I
actually don't know what it means right
so we're specifically talking about
is one machine is going to transact
value with another machine sewing
machine to machine transactions but this
is not necessarily just something they
do for fun right it's part of this
larger automation story and so maybe
start with just like what are some
examples of where two machines would
transact with each other in an automated
world yeah absolutely I think the best
IOT example is read a car the car is big
it has become incredibly smart we are
talking about autonomous vehicles we're
talking about cars that are collecting
gigabytes of data when you drive around
and all of that is because we want to
make smart decisions with our vehicles
and the car itself cannot collect all of
this data and so in what maybe wants to
collect data from a traffic light from
another vehicle of what the traffic
situation is lives so the most simple
machine-to-machine transaction is really
where one machine sells data to another
machine really insights so that the
machine itself can start making smarter
decisions based on the data that it gets
so take the car drives around right so
it has all of the GPS data right in
terms of like where has it actually gone
it has all the cars information how many
miles has it drawn was the mileage per
hour right you know all that kind of
stuff and then it also has I'm assuming
any sort of inputs into the car right so
that could be its interaction with
sensors it could be interactions with
the passengers who put information to
the car right those kind of that type of
data who would you be selling that to
right if you're the car yeah do it I
think the most important data buyer of
the future will be governments because
governments need to protect their
citizens they need to protect better
they need to provide better services to
the citizens and a good example is a
simple parking app knowing where when
and how a parking spot is available is
hugely valuable because it really eases
traffic congestion for example and it
really introduces new business models
for those that operate those parking
spots but today so and I think this is
gonna head down a direction those things
that that you and I have talked about
before today we have parking apps right
there's things that say hey I'll show
you where the parking spots are excetera
I can go to the
store download them for free yeah why
would why would that app want to buy
data versus just use the the free users
that it has today
I think this is the Saudis and an
excellent question really goes into this
broader vision of an open permissionless
ecosystem okay the problem that we have
today with those smart city apps is that
we're simply fragmenting the entire
ecosystem we have the over app we have
the Train app we have their airline app
but the entire user experience is well
if very fragmented I need to have an app
for each point where I'm travelling to
and the same with data points in the
future with this with this traffic app
or with this parking app they are all
not able to get the entire data set
within the city they're only able to get
those data sets where they actually have
access to and as such we are now really
limiting the user experience itself
because now you don't get all of the
data points within the city and now the
vision of iona is to really create an
open and permissionless way for
everybody to start selling and
participating in this data economy with
the idea behind that app start building
on top of it really have the holistic
picture where where something is
available where something is not
available and the idea here is we need
to break down those barriers and at the
end of the day what is a smart city for
who are their main customers it's the
citizens they want to make their user
experience they're their did the
services that are provided to them as
easy as possible and not secure as
possible and so as that's occurring
right that car that's driving around
it's gathering data today what would be
the way that somebody could purchase the
data from the car like what is the
legacy model look like we're a human
would be involved right and saying hey I
want to buy the data that's generated by
your car what does that look like so
it's simply not possible today
especially for the ank users to actually
purchase or sell their data it's simply
part of the entire and user experience
itself where the corporation's simply
take your data and district selling it
best example is Facebook and we also
seen this with some of the car
manufacturers where they're really
selling your data
as you're driving around what's what's a
good example is in airline industry
where the the planes no don't the plane
operators don't even own the turbines
but they're the data itself that is
generated from the turbines gets back to
the manufacturer so they can really do
predictive maintenance so they have like
a service level agreement that is part
of the entire acquisition of the turbine
mm-hmm and that means we are not really
having enabling data economy it's not
there yet today because really what
you're saying is there are people or
organizations that are generating the
incredibly valuable data right and right
now that data is just being taken by an
organization and that organization is
monetizing it but what should happen in
the future and what is likely to happen
in the future is that the person who
creates the the data will understand the
value of it and will actually monetize
it themselves
yeah exactly I think one of the most
exciting parts about this data economy
is how it will actually impact our
products that we purchased it
purchased today because the data
component itself can for example offset
the price of the product that you buy
you can go and say hey you can have
access to my data for a lifetime but I
want to get a cheaper product or you can
for example get the product itself for
free and you submit today the best
example is a weather station I did get
for free but you sell the weather data
and so it's probably very interesting
how companies in the future will start
competing with each other on this data
component but what needs to happen first
is that we really have this awareness
that our data is hugely valuable and
also what value it actually has we need
a price of your data for sure well and
for me the part that is interesting so
let's go to an extreme example right so
one of the hot topics in the United
States right now is universal basic
income so this whole idea that the
machines are going to displace a bunch
of workers those workers won't have
skills necessary to make a living so we
should step in and we should just give
these people money in order to provide
some base level you know affordability
of life there's an argument to be made
right I see the logic that somebody's
using for me I'm probably one of the
camp of those incentives seem a little
off right but the way that I would
makes sense to me to get the same impact
where people have money to live would be
this data monetization so I said for a
long time you know there's a lot of
people who would love to buy how many
steps I take what my heart rate is right
you know did I workout today did I not
how did I sleep what mobile applications
did I open what content did I consume
what music did I listen - where did I go
from GPS like all of this data that my
phone itself is able to track or
generate I'm giving it away to all of
those different service providers right
right but if instead I was able to
somehow hold on to it or retain it
bundle it up in different things right
so here's all my health data here's all
my exercise data here's my sleep data
here's my content data here's my
entertainment data whatever and then
half people basically come and purchase
it from me right so whether it's people
want it for research people want it for
marketing people want it for you know
whatever it is you know walkability in a
city whatever I could probably actually
if I had the demand and I had their
ownership of my data I could probably
generate a living just by simply selling
the data that I'm already generating
it's just that that mechanism isn't
there and the culture of monetizing data
doesn't exist yet yeah exactly and this
is really what distributed ledgers are
therefore to give people the freedom to
decide what should happen with their
data and what should happen with their
identities and who actually gets access
to that and you can in decide if you
want to start participating in this data
economy and you can really decide which
part of your data you can actually
monetize and when it comes to you VI and
and these kind of concepts I definitely
think that the whole vision of
automation and autonomy is to make our
lives easier to really move forward into
a much brighter future where where
machines start taking off some of our
hard work and hard labor today and
making much better and more
individualized products because that is
the big vision of industry 4.0 we want
to make machines that are not products
that are not mass-produced but really
products that are individually fit yep
and there's a very interesting concept
in also studies in
Germany where for example those cold
cobots meaning robots that work together
with humans that they find in their
cobots like co bo t yeah exactly so
collaborative mm-hmm they work together
with the humans in the factories and to
create a much safer environment for them
and they really help them also be more
efficient to also be more productive and
so how does that work they like talk
like give me an example of a co bot in a
manufacturing system the most simple
example is a human simply giving a metal
piece or something to a co bot who's
done processing it and and going really
from the raw product to to the produced
product got it so really the the co bot
if you will it's very similar to a
machine what we used to call a machine
right where maybe we had an assembly
line and somebody took something off the
assembly line and handed it to the
Machine and the Machine you know stamped
it or something the person who took it
back and put it back on the assembly
line right you know that that type of
interaction between machine and human
the Koba you're describing is really
similar it's just that the machine now
is smarter or could do more things than
just it's a single-use kind of stamp or
something yeah and it really creates a
much more safe environment for everybody
at the factory a good example is also in
in supply chain where you for example
don't have suction cups today that can
help you with delivering a product from
one factory flow to another factory
floor so you still need humans that are
involved in this entire process and and
Tom Lee from fonts thread made a very
interesting point that automation is
really a reaction to a labor shortage so
interesting so that means we need to
start innovating in order to make up for
this labor shortage because else we have
some serious problems the best example
is what's happening in trucking we have
a real shortage in a yes with truck
drivers and now we really need to start
thinking out with autonomous vehicles
now we can solve that problem and the
same is true with with Toyota right we
we are moving towards a future where
these technologies where you start to
converge a iio tlg and they create these
new systems of systems that will really
make of our future and we really just
start figure out how we can actually
nail those
and I guess as you start looking at the
machines interacting with each other
right go back to that the co bot example
really if we can get to a world where an
entire factory is autonomous right and
the factory can make decisions the
factory can produce things by simply
just sending it instructions you know
whether it's remotely or on-site that
world is going to require a lot of
innovation to get there like we are
nowhere near being able to do that today
yeah right
what do you think are the biggest
challenges between where we are today
and like a fully autonomous kind of
automated world I think a lot of this
has really more to do on the
philosophical and social side because
what we really need to create is a
future that is future proof something
that is not going to fundamentally
disrupt our society but it's really
something that is going to alleviate us
it's going to really help us move
forward into the future so that is why
we're ready to start thinking about what
kind of impact will a AI and guilty and
and IOT really have on this future and
how can you make sure that we have the
the DS this autonomous world functioning
with our human world and that is why
we're also going to see a much bigger
rise on in these social sciences in
universities to think about these heart
problems and the other problem is
obviously we need to start upgrading our
existing infrastructure which is know
concepts there is also one of the things
that we've seen while we are working
together with bigger corporates is like
how can you actually integrate the
distributed ledger on a very old system
that is currently running at the big
corporate when I still use old IBM
mainframes and stuff like that so it's
really about how can this new world
really be integrated in today into the
old world yeah and so one of the things
that you and I have talked about
previously that's very interesting to me
is the way that the machines interact
has various levels of complexity right
so there's the physical interaction
right one machine is touching another
machine one machine is
something to another like a kind of a
fully robotic world another component of
this is how they communicate with each
other right so in terms of I'm a machine
in the same room as another machine
I tell it what to do and then the third
is they transact with each other right
so I kind of think of it as there's
physical things to interact with there's
information to interact with and there's
value to interact with right now I think
that what you guys are doing is going
after the value interaction exactly but
let's talk about the first two first
right so physical interaction between
two machines I think is pretty
self-explanatory it's sending physical
item between the two can happen at all
kinds of different formats if you've
seen the videos of like Boston Dynamics
robots they can do all kinds of crazy
[ __ ] in terms of information I think
this is what most people think of as IOT
right it's it's the refrigerator saying
hey milk is coming you know is getting
low order more milk
tell Amazon to send milk right that to
me seems like we're actually making a
lot of progress so far in terms of where
we are technologically do you agree with
that or disagree with that yeah I think
I think I achieves no longer a buzzword
it was the birth birth 10-15 years ago
but now it really is starting to bear
its fruits meaning it's actually being
productive it's actually having an
impact on our lives that is sort of how
I always measure success for technology
can you really feel the impact of it and
with IOT especially in the industrial
world you can truly feel it and the most
talking about the communication side of
things the the most ironic part about
the Internet of Things is that is not
about the internet because Wi-Fi tcp/ip
and so no supporter really true and
consump energy consumptive for for
machines and so we you need to come up
with new protocols and make it actually
possible for one machine to connect to
talk with another machine and that is
why we really saw the rise of new
communication protocols like ZigBee
Laura when and so on and so forth that
make it possible with with little amount
of energy to actually transmit that data
and it also brings us into this whole
world of mesh networks where machine is
no longer connected to the clouds but
it's really a one machine connected to
others and other machines in this [ __ ]
computing environment and that is where
you need to start now introducing the
third layer which is this transactional
part so that the machine stem cells can
really start creating their own
consensus in this network can start
secure transactions and data I can start
transacting with each other from that
yeah and to me it feels like as you see
more and more machines come online that
are quote smart right so they have this
this connectivity if you will the
systems get smarter and they better
understand how to empower this and they
can also make better decisions right
it's kind of a true machine learning in
that the more data you put into the
system the better decisions they can
make the more they learn right and you
just kind of a compound effect to all
this which then the incentive would be
well let's get as many smart machines
onto the system as we possibly can
because it makes overall improvement so
whenever I give a presentation I always
have this like where where defined is
three steps of IOT okay so the first one
was dumped decentralization dumb central
decentralization don't decentralization
explain that so think about your old
washing machine that had a simple job to
do you press a button it starts twisting
around butylenes your clothing it was
not connected it could not do talk
without a machine yeah it was no smart
know where people don't even know how to
talk to their own washing machine let
alone talk to other machines that I keep
going
exactly so where we are today is smart
centralization okay that means we have
those devices that actually have more
computing capacity yep they have
connectivity they can transfer data and
most importantly they can really start
transmitting that data to the cloud we
are connected to your local Wi-Fi
network so now this washing machine
example is your washing machine can
really start figuring out when do you
actually want to have your your clothing
wash what what temperature is what are
what are your preferences and so on and
so forth and you can make smart
decisions like your thermostat nest
thermostat is a good example everything
because becomes automated because of the
cloud
yeah not because of the devices
themselves right the devices are only a
small component of this now the big
problem here is and that is why
distributed lectures are so exciting is
in the smart centralisation world we we
really have a single
point of failure which is the cloud the
cloud is a smart component here now if
the cloud goes offline or we'd have no
connectivity with a very expensive
device that is super stupid the
candidate we to automate my life and has
actually made it more difficult because
sometimes there's complete service
outage meaning I can no longer control
my a my temperature in my home and that
is why we need to move to the third step
which is smart decentralization okay so
they just as a recap the first step of
dumb decentralization is I have a system
in my homeless said the washing machine
the thermostat whatever it's
decentralized because it's not centrally
kind of aggregated with exact with
everyone else's washing machine right so
it's decentralized in that nature it's a
single node by itself that has no
connectivity but that's also why it's
dumb
Reis is unconnected the that's step one
step two is what users subscribe to a
smart centralization which is now the
machine actually has data capabilities
and some intelligence but the way that
that was accomplished was by connecting
them all to a central point right which
is the cloud so nest is nest HQ if you
will is the central point that all of
these nest smart devices are connected
to and there's benefits to doing that
cuz I can push updates I can do more
around learning and improve the software
whatever the downside is that there's
that central point of failure and you
know like smart centralization is all
about ownership do you actually own your
device if it's actually connected to the
cloud and can only really function with
the clouds and a very important question
is also do you own the data that is
being generated like today I think there
was an article that said nest owners
should tell their guests that they
should be aware that the nest of us can
start collecting their their talks their
conversations and it's kind of a scary
future and that is exactly where we are
today where those large corporations
actually own the devices they own the
ecosystem and they make decisions of
what happens with the data and with the
machines that are part of this ecosystem
nest tomorrow could just decide hey like
we want to discard this this product
because we no longer want to maintain it
is too expensive and now you as a
customer completely screwed yet you
cannot do
anything about that and it is exactly
why we need to change the ownership
structure of our IT ecosystems towards
is smart decentralization and I we have
I know that we are really big fans of
biomimetics meaning we want to imitate
nature okay in order to die oh man
ethics yeah okay imitating Nate okay go
ahead so a very interesting example is
how ants work orbs ants ants Oh ants
okay yeah the the European accent is
gonna throw me off ants amt sorry
so think about an ant us as an
individual IOT device okay it's dumb it
doesn't have the visual capacity to to
really figure out where to go what where
where's the thread where's food and so
on and so forth but the exciting part is
when you have a collective of ants and
what you're doing is they're sharing
data via pheromones so the more ants are
going in one direction the more ants are
starting to follow yep because they
start to understand like over there is
food or we need to help them and that is
why an anthill is one of the most
intelligent environments out there right
because they can really start building
up their own local ecosystem I even saw
some pictures of ants building boats and
driving around in rivers so it's really
crazy how a dumb device a young being
can create an collective intelligence
it's funny because there's humans they
don't have boats but the ants got boats
yeah absolutely
so and really what you're talking about
here is that collective intelligence
right this is pretty non-controversial
at this point that the power of the
crowd right and if we can actually use
sensors and machines and all this kind
of smart hardware to better collect then
to analyze and that eventually implement
the learnings from those data the
world's gonna be way better off than if
we couldn't do it exactly and not only
that but you also become much more
resilient against attacks so today we
live in an environment whereby we are
really we should be really worried about
hackers and how they can have
impact on our mission critical
infrastructure which is really the most
vulnerable part that we also have today
like our energy grid system and with
with this concept of smart isn't
realization of edge and for computing
and of making decisions locally in the
mesh of devices and simply sharing data
between devices with a much more secure
and much more resilient environment that
cannot be taken down meaning we remove
the civil point of failure that we have
today all right so I'm going to use an
example that I think illustrates this we
haven't talked about it so you gotta
tell me if I'm wrong or not I know it
should be honest the Apple iPhone to me
just is a great example of what you're
describing in the sense that take the
biometric so the the facial recognition
the the thumbprint right all these
things they're locally stored on the
consumer device so the Apple the company
gets hacked nobody can get my facial
recognition or my fingerprint but my
device is smart in that it uses all the
biometrics locally right and there is
now connectivity to my mobile carrier
right there's some sharing back to date
of other data back to Apple etc so it's
almost like you can pick or permission
what data gets shared with Apple what
data stays locally some of that's
determined by them in terms of how they
build the device right so there's just
no connectivity to send your biometrics
Apple but some of it is at the user
level I have control over the privacy of
my data yeah generally makes sense
around this kind of smart
decentralization notice a really good
example I can give you a better example
and also transcend into why you need to
create an open ecosystem which is
intelligence okay so so the best example
that we have today of network of devices
that is using these similar concepts is
Tesla which are autonomous vehicles so
what Tesla does is each node each car in
your network is collecting data as it
drives around and what they do now is
they start sharing this data with Tesla
HQ not with the auto test the vehicles
themselves but with a headquarter and
now the exciting part here is really the
entire network entire fleet of Tesla
cars becomes smaller
meaning that I really become a resilient
and I can actually really utilize with
ninety-nine percent failure rate my
autonomous driving but here's a problem
Tesla is a gated community they're their
own ecosystem and there's millions and
millions of cars out there that could
actually really benefit from the data
that Tesla has but Tesla is so much more
to benefit from them as well and now
here comes a vision of iota in how do
you break down those barriers so that
the Tesla vehicle is going to share data
with their the NOAA car with Volkswagen
car the way you can go about this is two
ways the first one is you do the
traditional way you create a new
consortium you know corporates they're
they'll act creating consortiums consort
us but I think now they're starting to
realize that this entire permission
environment is just creating too much
friction for them because now when you
want to join this consortium you have to
sign a contract you actually have to
make sure that there's no conflict of
interests and what will most likely
happen is that the other competitors are
going to create your own consortium and
know that we have them competing if you
have full fragmentation of exactly now
you're really fragmented and now the
ones that benefit though don't benefit
are the end consumers because now the
data is not being shared so how do you
break down those barriers
you simply introduce an incentive
mechanism every every company wants to
make money that's there there's a goal
right and yeah and a very good point
that was made recently is data should be
part of your balance sheet of a large
corporation and now what happens in this
in this in this vision is that Tesla
started to sell data to full-on children
or to purge all and so on and so forth
and it's not transacting with each other
so they start to benefit from each other
by simply selling data and through that
you start to get these intelligence out
of that so what are you guys doing in
the space right with I would like what
what is the vision of what you want to
build and then we can get kind of get
into what the components role what
ultimately what somebody says you know
what are you building what exactly is
that so we are focused on a value
lair we really want to be the trust
layer of our digital economy meaning
that we are the open permissionless
protocol that everybody can go to if
they want to secure data or if they
really want to enable payments which
obviously require trust that you can
trust it is going to be submitted and
it's going to be confirmed and it's
actually secure and so we are really
sort of the middle layer here that
enables this vision of a machine economy
so in our our future that we envision is
that every device has their own wallet
and it can really start transacting
through iota so going back to that
example of kind of there's physical
objects that can be transacted between
two right so a machine enhanced ultimate
machine there's information right which
is more kinda I Oh tea and in smart
device and then this third bucket is
really what you guys are attacking which
is the the transfer of value or
transactions that you don't can make how
is that being done today right is this
simply something where you know I walk
in this Starbucks and I have got a QR
code and my device which is my
smartphone that I'm physically holding
hits the scanner and then there's a
payment made in the backend is that kind
of the the smartest version of how a
quote machine-to-machine transaction
works today in short when it comes to
the value transfer yeah yeah that's a
good example and we we also have our own
wallet where we really focus on those
more consumer payments but fundamentally
what we are doing is how can we
integrate our our software into the car
into the machine itself on the hardware
that is why we also developing our own
hardware for example to accelerate the
algorithms and so on and so forth
because that is the big vision you want
to remove the trust barrier here and the
machine itself should be a full
knowledge it should really participate
in a network and it should be able to
easily transact with another machine and
you know the exciting part about micro
payments is that it's action mechanism
to remove trust so now if you start
charging with that with a charging
station in the future how can in this
autonomous future how can a charging
station actually know that a car is
there
unless we really have an identity
protocol the only way to remove distrust
is by making it possible for the car to
pay the charging station and as soon as
the payment the micro payment is done
the charging station will release the
energy flow and now the car can able is
able to verify hey I'm getting
electricity I should release more
payments and through that you start you
have a very interesting mechanism to
remove trust in our society okay so
let's talk about let's use a car as an
example right so I think that's one you
guys have done some work on and I've
thought about there's a lot of payments
that a car is involved in we don't think
about today right at a normal human I go
to get gas I get out of my car I put my
credit card of the Machine I plug in the
gas right pump and then I start pumping
gas into my car I physically as a human
had to get out of my car and do an ID
card a toll I Drive I gotta stop my car
I got to reach out I got to put change
in or or I give them some kind of you
know pass etc no part charging parking
right I mean there's a lot of things you
do with your car a speeding ticket I
thought I went too fast I gotta pay
right I'll stop what you're really
talking about is removing the friction
of the human element of those
transaction where the end results is
saying I get gas I paid for it right or
I get electricity I paid for it in terms
of lecture car I drove on this road I
paid a toll right I went too fast I paid
a penalty but what you're really talking
about is just as you remove that human
it becomes more efficient on how to do
that because the machine the car itself
is able to directly transact with
whoever the recipient of the funds oh
yeah yeah exactly and and this is what I
mentioned before this is really the next
step of automation which is autonomy and
dead that fundamentally frees us humans
up from from some of these very mundane
tasks like getting out of your car
getting a parking ticket and stuff like
that you can really start automating all
of this by simply introducing payment
mechanisms or data transfer mechanism
and that is what we are fundamentally
focused on and that is why also so many
corporates and governments are super
excited about this future because for
them they also understand that these are
new business models for them and new
revenue streams and they make their
their cars so much more appealing to
purchase as well for example we we have
an exciting work together with Jaguar
Land Rover where they introduce that the
car can now have an i/o dakari wallet
that we're working on and now I can
really start also selling data as it
drives around okay all right so let's
make sure I understand this in this
partnership that you guys have with
Jaguar Land Rover you're going to put
software on the car itself that allows
them have a digital wallet that digital
wallet can do two things as my
understanding one it can hold money
right digital currency and then it can
pay that to certain sensors or kind of
counterparties for certain activity so
whether that is gas tolls electricity
whatever but the second thing is there's
also the ability for the car to sell the
data it's generating and in return
receive payment into that digital wallet
for having sold the data that it was
generating all right yeah exactly and
this is what the machine economy itself
is about the machine store are not just
consumers also become prosumers and they
start generating data so much data that
is hugely valuable to other machines
best example is the Waze app Waze as it
works today said you as a human you have
to manually manually enter here's
something here's that bla bla bla bla
right and that creates friction because
I think 90% of people do not want to do
that because there is no incentive but
now the car itself is the best
autonomous vehicle or like autonomous
machine driving around because as you
drive around you generate data and you
can start selling that you have a
pothole you can sense that and then you
can submit the data you're stuck in
traffic you can submit the data and that
is really the exciting part about this
future right how can we make it possible
for these machines to just start
functioning like ends transmitting data
so I want to play devil's advocate right
there's a lot of people who are
listening to this who are going to
you're full of [ __ ] right and and not in
a you know what you're saying is wrong
of the wall that we're going into but
there's other ways to do some of this
right so look I'm gonna throw out what I
think are the arguments of the
detractors and then you respond so first
is yes we're going to an automated world
yes there'll be machine to machine
transactions but we already have a
digital currency we have a Bitcoin right
and the machines are going to use
Bitcoin not something else so why don't
you just go focus on Bitcoin so I think
the first answer to the question is that
we are not competing with Bitcoin
Bitcoin has a very different appeal to
holders and to investors and to users
now the focus of iota and that is
exactly why we actually created iota is
to really be a machine currency that
removes the friction that has a
technology as its backbone that is
actually capable of running in an IOT
environment okay so a machine currency
I've never heard anyone talk about them
for what does that mean simply a
currency that that is is in particular
designed and built to enable these
machine to machine transactions okay and
in like from a technical standpoint what
is the difference in how machines
transact versus how let's say you and I
would send Bitcoin back apart I think
the biggest difference is simply in the
size of the transactions as humans we
want to send around hundreds thousands
of dollars in Bitcoin for remittances
purposes right no machine wants to do a
simple micro payment for data set for
certain service that just takes a few
seconds to complete and so you want to
be able to transmit a fraction of that
transaction of that value of a normal
value of the transaction and now with
iota what we are really focused on how
can we make it possible for these micro
transactions to actually happen without
any fees so that is why we introduced
iota in 2015 which is new technological
concept called to tangle based on a DAC
okay and what is that so it's a directed
acyclic graph oh my god you're these big
words from smart people all right it's a
directed acyclic okay graph graph and
what does that mean so if you think
about the blockchain
sequential sequential chain block of the
block of the block if that in certain
intervals 10 minutes for example gets
confirmed by a smaller subset of the
network which is the miners so data one
surrogate that are responsible for the
consensus in fundamentally now with iota
instead of having the sequential chain
we remove the blocks and remove the
chain okay so what do you replace them
with transactions so one trigger if you
execute a transaction in iota it doesn't
get bundled into a block it simply gets
attached to this tangle so that means
your transaction references to
transactions in a history and now where
the consensus comes from is that the
more transactions confirm your
transaction the more secure it gets so
you have a similar principle mm-hmm and
now obviously the complexity is how will
you get that confirmation but that is
why why we published a lot of white
papers and it is also why we are right
now working on removing the friction
that we have today we need a coordinator
meaning reading really having a protocol
that is fit for IOT so our big goal is
it for next year 2020 to really be
production ready and to enable thousands
of transactions per second and to start
onboarding some of the bigger corporates
that we already have as partners today
onto the network
meaning that they will actually utilize
the permissionless network and will
actually utilize the ánotá token got it
and so before we get to the token
component one of the things you said to
me before that I don't understand as
well so so it would be helpful to
understand is most human-to-human
digital currency transactions happen on
the Internet yeah a lot of
machine-to-machine transactions don't
actually happen over like tcp/ip right
so maybe describe a little bit about
what the differences between how some of
these machine transactions are occurring
versus how the like let's say Bitcoin
transactions are happening on the
Internet and how you guys are addressing
the machine-to-machine side of this yeah
I think a good analogy to this is
awesome what you want to achieve of
sharding so that meaning means that you
you have a global ledger which is the
the ultimate settlement layer but then
you also enable starts in this network
and one shard can be a participant of
devices meaning a cluster of devices
that
build their own mesh networks and the
reason why you want to do that is
because sometimes those devices are
offline
sometimes those devices use a very
different communication protocol like I
mentioned before but you still want to
enable the business model to them
meaning transacting value and this is
what we are at the Yoda are really focus
on first we want to get the base layer
right make that fully scalable and then
the next iteration is we need to enable
sharding so that we enable those cluster
of devices to restart transacting with
each other and you know how difficult
starting is with with with blockchain
because it wasn't really impossible yet
and so we work on this for the last five
or six years on sharding and nothing has
really come out yet mmm-hmm so why do
you think it hasn't been there's been no
progress yet I think it really has to do
with building on the wrong principles
and when we started I Yoda or me like we
still say that everything is a proof of
concept Bitcoin is a proven concept
ioad is a proven concept if theorem is a
proof of concept we need to actually
prove that those technologies have
real-world impact and are scalable and
that is why we need to focus first on
scaling these technologies and and
getting them production ready we're not
there yet and with Schrodinger there
there's a lot of interesting research
arounds but I've not really seen
anything being concretely implemented
yet and if it is some of the bigger
projects like us or like Bitcoin and
sunspot will hopefully start
implementing those got it so let's go
back to the game of devil's advocate
right so that there's Bitcoin and then
you've got the iota system a lot of
people I think would say hey you don't
need a token right the iota token itself
you could do all this without a token
you say what so so there's four
different answers that I think maybe
five or six okay just thinking it
through the first answer is very simple
we don't have digital identities and as
I mentioned before digital identities
remove the trance barrier but we know
we're not there yet and as such we need
to have a token so that the machine has
a wallet is able to
the Trust's and the friction by
transacting with the other machine and
making sure that the values actually
being transferred like their energy flow
as I mentioned before so that is the
first reason no digital identities the
second reason is IOT is not about the
Internet and we need to make it possible
for this machine to machine payments to
actually happen in the future we're not
going to envision machines sending an
API request to to a bank and saying
please transfer money from my bank
account to another Bank you have a
machine that simply doesn't work and
it's not scalable especially if we talk
about billions of devices - exactly we
are simply gonna have network congestion
well and also I think it's a time so one
of the things I always joke about is you
can't have an instantaneous or automated
system and if you wait a day for the
bank to settle the payment exactly and
that's just ridiculous the third reason
is micro payments I don't know of any
protocol or any traditional financial
instrument that enables you to do micro
payments in a trustless way especially
and you disgust me
IOT machine to machine transactions are
all about micro payments and the
exciting part about micro payments is
that you get this fine granularity of
what you're actually paying for meaning
you don't have a monthly subscription
service but the only paper usage unit
per minute that uses robotic arm and
it's really unlocked so much more
capital as well and now the fourth
reason is what actually got me into this
whole DLT space is permissionless
innovation we want to have an open and
permissionless network that is not owned
by single entity we're no consortium
makes decisions but where we have an
open way for people to participate and
to and to benefit from this ability to
transact value mm-hmm and so another
question that I think comes up is this
isn't a blockchain right I think you can
already answered that with it's the DLT
components are there it is not a chain
of blocks of transactions yeah yeah and
we were the first ones to truly
introduce Dax back in 2015 and what is
it at
okay well directed acyclic graph okay
yeah and we've seen many projects now
also start utilizing Dax so it's really
a confirmation and by the way just so
you know my co-founder come from beyond
was also the first one to develop the
foolproof estate blockchain riddle he
was with pioneer in this space since
2011 2012 so we really have this deep
technological knowledge of the LTS but
really now our our goal and our job us
as a project is to cross this technology
chasm as I mentioned before everything
is a proof of concept today how do we
actually make sure that those
technologies are ready and I think when
it comes to making sure that these
projects already there is like three
ways to look at it first obviously
technology it needs to be scalable and
it needs to be validated that is
scalable the second one is governance
and I think governance is one of the
most underrated concepts in this space
because you don't want to have a
for-profit entity owning this this
protocol where we envision billions of
dollars to be transacted with I just
think there's a huge conflict of
interest because they also benefit the
most from it and governance is really
where we make sure that the protocol
itself is not going to be developed by
one entity but is being hosted in a
vendor neutral environment I mean in a
corporate startups developers everybody
can start participating and making
collective decisions on what should be
the future of the protocol similarly to
how TCP IP is being further developed or
the Linux kernel those are hugely
valuable and pieces of technology where
we need to have a proper governance
framework around that and it's
especially important for a protocol
where the values being transacted and as
my governance is really what many more
projects in space should look out for
and the third one is obviously ecosystem
we need to have people built around and
build on top mmm-hmm and so talk to me
about two three five years from now what
are some of the applications that come
on to the network that you get the most
excited on so
the car right and kind of the digital
wallet in a car I could see that
happening very quickly right yeah what
are some of these other applications
that you see that you're like look we
not only are excited but we think that
they're they're viable and the kind of
two to five year time frame yeah so as I
mentioned I think the machine wallet
itself is gonna be the biggest
application because now we can really
make it possible for these machines to
actually start providing the service
like manufacturing on the Mart will be
huge in the future where a large
corporates no longer need to have huge
and capital expenditures on acquiring
the machines but they simply leased them
on demand so that will be huge but I
think there's many other very exciting
concepts like the data economy part
where we are also really thinking about
AI and so one of the most exciting
concepts for for me is really federated
machine learning okay explain that so
federated machine learning can be
explained quite simply instead of
sending the data to the algorithm you
Sonny the algorithm to the data that
means the devices are no longer
transacting there the gigabytes of data
to the cloud where the cloud is now the
smart engine but the edge itself the
devices start collecting the data just
start and analyzing the data and what
did you then is they start sharing the
insights with each other Oh interesting
so rather than me be the car that takes
all the data I have send that data
somewhere it's analyzed in the cloud and
then basically I get the insights back
and then everyone else gets insights
instead all of that computation and
analysis happens at the car level and
then all I'm transacting is the final
insights to whether there's a central
party or another you know decentralized
node in a network yeah and the exciting
part is that you can really make a data
privacy preserving AI application
meaning your sensitive data does not get
shirt your Fitbit is actually smart on
its own but it also becomes even smarter
from all the other fit bits that are
around because people are sharing data
but no sensitive data gets shared
and that will really unlock so much more
potential for the future whereby AI
which as everybody agrees is here is
having an impact but AI today is really
something that is there just to get as
much data from you as possible
that is why Google and Facebook are
really dominating and today
now with federated machine learning
you're really starting to solve these
problems of data data gathering and data
collection and make it possible for
these machines to also start selling
those insights with IOT tokens so they
stop paying each other and they
collectively get smarter and then
there's a high probability this is the
world moving right I think that we kind
of both agree that an autonomous
automated world it's more a question of
when not if what's the ethical concerns
or or the potential downsides of doing
that's right I think you know as
technologists we always get excited
about oh look at this world we can go
build okay always benefit what's the
downside that people should either be
aware of or are thinking about as we
move towards as well
the downside is really on building
something that is not future proof what
do you mean by that so one of the most
interesting books that I read like a
year or two ago was called the master
switch and it talks about how does very
exciting technological advances start
out in a decentralized way but any stop
becoming more centralized so it's really
a cycle mmm a good example is what
happened with the telephone system where
initially it was very decentralized you
had those farmers operating the switches
and then AT&T came aboard they started
building up those huge mess and
everything and they started owning the
network itself owning the ecosystem and
now we have their their ridiculous price
policies and the same happened with the
internet where by now we have those huge
conglomerates that own the Internet and
they also own you and own your data and
that is why the Internet has become this
double-edged sword we talked about we
want to connect as many people as
possible but now we're starting to
realize them like the Internet is
actually having an impact on our
democracy which is what fundamentally
protects us as well from
bad decisions and now we are really in
an environment where the Internet is
having a negative impact and with
technologies like AI and distributed
letters we also need to think about how
can we make this system future proof
that we don't have a similar situation
again that a few monopolies is a few
large companies are owning their
respective ecosystems and are owning the
protocol itself and they're making bad
decisions on our behalf and so can we
prevent some bad stuff or do you think
it's something that we just have to be
aware of and it's a necessary evil with
the progress that that it comes with
sadly I think it's the latter big
gorilla yeah because that's that's why
we have coined this right it's just too
much of a pain in the ass to store your
own tokens and you're worried about
losing it now we start going to the
centralized provider since those
centralized providers are really there
to solve the entire UI and UX problem
that we have so I hope that we can
figure out a way on how to resolve those
issues but I think the the only way to
really resolve that from ever happening
is to make the right policies and the
right regulation and that always assumes
that we have the right people in place
to make those decisions and that's why I
always say is that we cannot do this
alone we need to bring the old world
with the new world together to really
start building a framework to make sure
that this is something that will last
decades and will truly bring prosperity
to all of us and only by by bringing the
Nerds and the policymakers together we
can make that happen yeah and I guess
what do you guys do as you're building
out kind of the connectivity right it's
really how I think but you're building
the network where you can transact value
on for these machines how do you
interface with the corporate partners
how do you interface with like industry
associations just people who are working
on similar types of problems and want to
see the same world but they're just not
focused on this part of the technology
stack yeah so I think that IOT is really
one of the top three ecosystems in the
space in terms of corporate adoption and
also our community and since the
inception we always said is that we work
for and with the industry we are really
building a technology
that sauce industrial problems and we
have some very big corporates that we
have us partners that are really
starting to develop together with us
like Jaguar Land Rover like
stmicroelectronics like an Aggie net and
an NG and Sona support all of those
really large conglomerates that are
starting to realize they need to invest
now into a technology like iota to start
building business models for the future
who are the other who are the other 2d
thinker are just as big
I think hypo Legendre theorem really not
Bitcoin I think in corporate adoption
incorporated apps yeah yeah you got it
okay I know general adoption I think
Bitcoin is definite the biggest yeah
from a user standpoint got it but really
from like a partnership standpoint et
cetera
yeah it's a big bitcoins Business
Development Department is lacking my
favorite all right so as you guys are
building out the corporate partnerships
etc where do you see those people today
in terms of their receptivity right so
some organizations obviously oh hey
let's we'd love to work on this now I'm
assuming there's still some who are
desire we're not ready or not we kind of
are skeptical of this stuff so I think
especially after the bust of 2018 yeah
yeah we we saw a little bit of less
responsiveness and less interest but I
think those companies that are truly
committed today they've started
investing more resources into this and
they have also shown much more
commitment and this stage that we are at
right now is that we have a
self-sufficient ecosystem me that
corporates come to us and say hey like
we've actually built as an iota do we
want to do a partnership announcement
and stuff like that so that's really the
station we at right now where why we're
starting just to see the snowball
rolling faster and faster also because
we are part of some large and industrial
associations we started to work on
standardization and corpus start to
realize we need to get into this now and
also this entire space has matured a lot
we got rid of all the [ __ ] from 2017
where companies were bombarded by moon
boys they were bombarded by ICO projects
and now it's really about value
because what is what what distributed
letters were really invented for and
what bitcoin was invented for is it to
truly change what is wrong today to
really change this this trust level that
we have today and improve it
significantly and also introduces new
open trust layer to this to society that
says benefiting all of us not just the
corporates but also the citizens and
individuals that live up in this cities
for sure when people who are listening
to this leave what's the one thing that
you want them to kind of walk away with
or when they think of iota they think of
what you guys are building kind of
what's that you know one or two
sentences just hey here's how I want
people to view the world through our
perspective I think that iota is not
just a cryptocurrency it's not just
another speculative asset it's really
something where we are focused on what
are the fundamentals and how do we get
those fundamentals rights and how can we
make sure that the currency part in
encrypt the currency actually comes back
because today all cryptocurrencies are
speculative assets and we want to make
the jump and actually have something
where machines start transacting with
each other where we have an economy that
is starting to really make up our future
as a we are we as a nonprofit foundation
are really focused on building towards
the future and and we don't see
ourselves as competing with other
projects we don't want to get into
fights but we focus on value creation
and I think other projects should focus
on the same and you think cars and the
in kind of this machine wallet is the
first place where the adoption really is
gonna take off and also on the data
security part having an audit rate of
your vehicle and after the telemetry
data is a good example or supply chain
data those are the areas where I think
we will see the first adoption and then
it will start reading going and growing
from there when it comes to smart cities
smart cities are themselves are very
interesting because what is a smart city
smart cities transportation its supply
chain is energy and we need to start
combining all of these different
verticals and industries into one
machine economy that is why I'm also
very much against utility tokens because
they serve no purpose
because you start just creating more
friction and more barriers mm-hmm
what um before I wrap up each episode I
always asked kind of rapid-fire
questions what uh what's the most
important company crypto other than
Europe and most important company in
crypto I definitely think right now it's
these type of exchanges that take
regulations seriously and that are
starting to build for the future because
when I have when I have a big partner
speaking with a big partner I'm not
gonna sent them to a corporation Hong
Kong to do kyc so it's really about
those exchanges that are built to last
as well and take regulation take data
protection everything very seriously
yeah it's kind of yet to provide value
to your customers all right and exam
that definition is changing depending on
what customer is coming up at the
desired customer what uh what's the one
regulation that you would change or
improve if you could change any of them
in Germany or anywhere in the world you
pick your your more global than I am so
you pick what which jurisdiction you
would choose I think really data
protection laws I won't start
introducing much more data protection
laws globally because that is what's
really required for us to also start
speeding up the adoption of distributed
Ledger's as a whole but we are actually
seeing that in the United States where
California is really leading these new
data protection acts and I think those
are really those type of laws that we
need to focus on right now what's the
most controversial thought you have in
in awe of Bitcoin crypto iota world
the most controversial thought is
probably like can you talk about other
specific projects you can do whatever
you want that some of the major projects
in the top ten top twenty are planned
pump and dump schemes do you want to
name any of them no I don't think so
I thought I was gonna get you to me
alright I don't know if that's
controversial I think that a lot of
people might agree with you I think if
it wouldn't he know would be
controversial maybe okay what is the
most important book that you've ever
read the most important book that I ever
read was probably one of the most
interesting one was the age of
surveillance capitalism okay that's a
recent book right yeah a relatively
recently yeah exactly dan simmerman from
my team this is chilling it everywhere
okay but it brings very interesting
perspective about these ecosystems
evolved and why these companies actually
make those decisions and how they
perceive you and but other than that
there's AI I read a lot of research
papers in a space but right now what I'm
really focused on is is less about the
future more about the present meaning
I'm starting reading a lot about
management books and I've deleted big
team yeah we're in the foundation we're
now 120 hundred and thirty people Wow
120 130 people yeah that's a lot of
people in 23 countries so it's very
decentralized yeah yeah that's a lot of
people where do you find them all on the
internet just that different like job
recruiting website yeah wow that's
pretty cool yeah we grew quite a lot and
so you need to focus on organizational
structures and so on and so forth so
that's also what excites me being a
leader of this and figuring out how we
can really also start building new
ventures in his ecosystem and being a
CEO type person yeah that's really
really cool but in general I want to
read more but like during during the
stressful year of the last two years 12
30 months I wasn't able to read much
it's just jump on Twitter Twitter's
always got an opinion about something
before we end you get asked me a
question but first we talked a lian's
believer or non-believer let's put it
this way if aliens exist I hope that
they're not gonna come right now on
earth because the road is pretty [ __ ]
okay you hope that they don't come
interesting Wyatt why do you hope that
they don't come I'm
there the world is in a pretty bad shape
right now and we need to get our ranks
together especially on misinformation
and how easy it is to spread it and know
seeing it the aliens gain they would
tell everyone that they're not here and
then we would all believe that they're
not here yet
I would probably shake their head and
fly back yeah you guys are idiots yeah
we actually want nothing to do with this
forget we were ever here see ya all
right what one questions do you have for
me what question I have for you is like
how do you think that this space is
going to you evolve over the next year
what what really excites you yeah
so when most people ask me what does the
space need I say time so I get more
excited the longer the time line is
right so one year away it looks pretty
similar to where we are today right yeah
maybe you know there's some prices move
there's some more companies that come in
and start building with you know Bitcoin
and blockchain zand and different
technologies there's more startups for
sure that kind of you know start
creating things um so you get progress
all right there's like twelve months
there's only so much that can happen in
it right have you said to me how excited
am I about five years from now I'm
getting pretty excited right you say to
be 20 years from now I'm really excited
you're right yeah and it's just because
with more time comes more opportunity
right and ultimately I have a deep
conviction in kind of where that world
ends up and so it's just the more time
that we're given the more I think that
gets done and even if you look at you
know the the easiest example is if you
were to look at the number of companies
the number of people operating in the
industry and then the number of people
who are signed up at exchanges or using
some of these products through 2018 the
numbers usually actually went up yeah
right so even then when prices were
going the opposite direction then where
most people wanted the usage and a lot
of this stuff was actually going in the
other direction right
you know the Bitcoin one is the one I
see people cite the most on Twitter of
the hash rate so prices going down hash
rate is four axing that's a pretty
interesting counter sick
in terms of where that what's going on
the price so if that's happening in the
quote bear markets well what's gonna
happen when we go back into the bull
markets right obviously there's going to
be a lot of excitement and I actually
think that the next bull market will
make the last one look pretty small
right and so when that happens like
let's you know hold on
rakes it seemed to be pretty exciting
stuff no I think it will be very
exciting and and I think now people
really understand it there's a lot of
potential and we are here to stay and
that is what everybody should understand
that this is not going away
absolutely where can people find you on
the internet and find out more about
iota so they can find out more about
iota iota dark my ot a dot org and you
can follow me on twitter at dom she nerd
do em SCH IE and e are awesome in well
listen thank you so much for doing this
i think that uh you know you and i have
talked to the past and obviously this
conversation around just automation and
it kind of autonomous world that we're
heading into where machines are
transacted with machines is it's gonna
happen
right this is very exciting it's just a
question to kind of you know who are the
players and and then you know what's
kind of the sequential rollout or
adoption of this but but i don't find
very many people who argue with the idea
that automation is gonna happen yeah
exactly the only thing we we need to
focus on is to do it the right way
yeah make it future-proof i I love the
terminology future-proof so you want to
bring you back on at some point in the
future and kind of get an update as to
where you guys are and then get a lay of
the land when it comes to machine to
machine transactions yeah thank you very
much hey everyone
pop here if you like this episode of off
the chain and want to help us take
crypto to the top of the Apple Spotify
and other podcast charts please do us a
favor and rate review and subscribe to
review simply go to the off-the-chain
home page scroll down until you see the
five blank stars taking 15 seconds to
fill those stars in and leave a quick
review goes a long way in helping us
take the entire crypto ecosystem to the
top of the charts I appreciate you
listening and see you next time on off
the chain
you